angels not gonna move on me again is it
and let me check
[Applause]
[Music]
the time of angels and flesh in stone
first two parter of the steven moffat
era first two parter for matt smith and
the first two parter of series five this
is okay this one I've always filed under
good but overrated or at least
historically I have a feeling people are
a bit softer on it than they used to be
although I'm not sure it's because of
anything that actually goes on in this
episode I think it's mostly because the
angels are now pretty much universally
recognized as having diminishing returns
each time they showed up again and so
people now tend to bolon every
appearance of the weeping angels that
isn't blink but I actually had issues
with this thing from its original airing
so for my part I'm gonna try and not get
hung up on there were later appearances
and how well they were or weren't use
then this story in and of itself is a
bit of a mixed bag for me for a number
of reasons and it it is a combination of
being incredibly intricate and
articulately planned while at the same
time leaving me with a lot of wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
moments at the same time and that is
really frustrating for me because I'd
like to think I'm pretty good at meeting
something halfway at accepting it on its
own terms when it comes to things like
wilful suspension of disbelief
that's why I don't get overly hung up on
things that you know oh but it was this
before if we're dealing with completely
different stories as far as I'm deserved
when you have something like Doctor Who
then for the most part certain things
that connect episode / episode accepted
but for the most part because every
story is in a new setting in a new time
period with often a brand new villain
you're allowed to reset the bar for what
is or isn't you know the acceptable
level of willful suspension of disbelief
some people can't do that I usually can
where I have problems is where
elements don't feel like they don't play
fair they don't play by the own rules
that they themselves appear to be
setting out and there's some of that at
play here despite the fact that as I
said it feels at times to be really
carefully meticulously plotted and then
there's other stuff it's like okay so
here we go
return of River Song that's fun and I
like that and Alex Kingston thankfully
her flirty energy works just as well
with Matt Smith as it did with David
Tennant even though Matt Smith is a very
different doctor than David Tennant was
it still bounces off the energy that
she's bringing very very well that was
actually something I had been really
afraid of way back when this first aired
is the is it gonna feel like the same
dynamic and for the most part yeah yeah
it does a bit different on the doctors
part cuz now he knows who she is but
like for her rent know that's keeping
true to it um a meze greated I really do
like a me a lot and revisiting this
series is really reminding me how much I
liked her and rose fans are gonna hate
on me with this I'm gonna continue to
compare her to Rose because again her
opening pitch as a character on paper
could have been very similar to Rose but
she is very different so like here's a
good example when she sees the doctor
flirting with River or River flirting
with a doctor and the doctor more or
less accepting it she's intrigued and
she starts teasing him and ribbing him
for it I couldn't help but think boy if
this was rose she'd be pitching a little
passive-aggressive fit right now but Amy
despite the fact that it will be
demonstrated by the end of the episode
that she does flat-out have the hots for
him that she's just like oh well okay
then and I just kind of like that about
Amy personally
so we have the return of the weeping
angels we have the wonderful Ian Glenn
playing a father Octavian who's you know
in who's in custody of not in custody
his has River Song in his custody and is
basically monitoring her the whole side
of buh-bye
Zann team is kind of cool I do like I
actually do really like the doctor in
the museum and him just going through
wrong wrong very wrong Oh what of mine
like that's that's a great moment
because that that's the kind of thing
that I always imagined tends to happen
between adventures of Doctor Who between
situations where it is life and death is
is the doctor doing stuff like that so
it's I love moments like that obviously
you can't have a whole episode there's
nothing but that but I'd like when those
moments get slipped in and I feel like
we get a glimpse of a more laid-back day
with the doctor so I think that's really
cool and really fun so let's talk about
the Angels the angels
I actually think are pretty well
utilized here we get some new wrinkles
in terms of how they operate and the way
that they function that I think are
pretty neat the whole thing with the
image of an angel becomes an angel first
we get with the TV monitor which that's
creepy as heck the way that builds and
how that plays out and then with Amy
that it's literally in her eyes like Oh
Rudd and I remember thinking as I was
watching oh is this gonna now be like
well why didn't they crawl into the eyes
and in blink but then two things
occurred to me one they were only
looking they could only see the Angels
eyes like towards the very end of that
thing because part of that the angel
always had that going on and the other
thing is I'm prepared to take as
headcanon that when the aim angels
basically perma froze each other that
that basically would have canceled out
whatever residual image any one of those
specific angels would have done now
that's head can in my case but it's
enough that I'm prepared to roll with it
now when I say that elements don't play
fair the main thing that I'm talking
about here is the cracks in time and
I'll decide this as I get towards the
tail end of this series but I may have
to devote an episode entirely to this
specific series arc because first of all
like I'll admit to having a distaste for
it because it fits
the the mystery box template that I'm
just sick of and don't particularly
enjoy but beyond that the rules of these
things are really all over the place and
they basically seem to be the cracks in
time do whatever we want them to do for
this particular story and I'm okay with
them functioning differently under
different circumstances but it's not
really ever acknowledged it just kind of
happens and the big example here at this
point is because now we basically see
what the cracks in time do like and why
they were a threat because up to this
point they were just kind of there I
don't know why that's there keep showing
up that's weird
now it's actually be it's not actually
posing a direct threat but first episode
of this series the eleventh hour they
were used as a portal Prisoner Zero used
it to escape from one point in space and
time to another and the cracks never
function like that again and that's kind
of what I mean by it's not playing fair
it's not obeying its own rules and I
will readily admit we get very loose and
scant things as to how these things work
and normally that's enough for me to
roll with okay I don't need it
explicitly laid out and I don't unless
you've got it doing stuff that feels
contradictory to the other stuff you
also have any doing that you kind of do
need to cover and it doesn't and there's
also a lot of little tiny moments that
just don't quite work for me so like
when the when the doctor stays behind
briefly and the Angels catch him by the
by the back of the coat why did they
freeze because they're behind it so like
one of them grabs his coat he's like aah
and it's stoned behind him why he can't
see it he's not he doesn't crane his
neck back to be able to see them and
then he runs away he's back to them and
they don't give chase they're still
frozen whoo
looking at them well what huh
also this seems to all really violate
the angels can freeze in the sight of
each other rule because there's a
massive amount of them and they don't
appear to be freezing from the sight of
each other I mean maybe that's why they
froze but if that's the way it works
then like the whole way that they that
they would have to move as a group is
like one gets this far for then like
maybe kind of but the way they're
visualized doesn't really quite flow and
jibe with that and again even if that is
the reason that like they froze when
they grab the doctor's coat whichever
ones were furthest forward should have
been able to chase him yet somehow they
didn't or couldn't and it's it wouldn't
bother me if the Angels as an entity as
a villain felt so carefully thought out
and plotted and so meticulously applied
the last time that they appeared and in
certain aspects of how they appear here
but then in other ways it's very sloppy
and very very loosey-goosey in terms of
how it's working and it's that contrast
I can work with looser rules I can work
with tighter rules but it's when you
appear to be operating by tighter rules
but are actually being really loose with
them you start to bug me you start to
annoy me when you do that I also and
I've mentioned this before I don't love
the fact that basically this problem
would've solved itself now the doctor is
not an active participant in the defeat
of the Angels the reason they lose is
because the thing that they were already
doing draining the energy from the ship
meant the gravity gave out meant they
fell into the crack and that would have
happened regardless of whether or not
the doctor had shown up so I I've gotten
a little better on that point in general
but I realized why I was so hard on it
in the past it's because the show tries
to paint it like he did something and he
didn't because you know when he says to
River and Amy
get a grip which is a good line and a
good strategy once he realizes something
that nobody else has the fact that River
goes oh you genius and then the big
triumphant music hits his theme you know
as if he made this happen and she's
praising him like he tricked them into a
situation he didn't all he did was
recognize the situation they already
created for themselves he's not a genius
he's lucky and I'm okay with the doctors
skirting by by the skin of his teeth and
being lucky honestly I'd like to see it
more often but don't play it off like
this was his plan so III have a feeling
that that's why that thing's stuck in my
craw more so it's not the fact that he's
not an active participant it's the fact
that the show is presented in such a way
that it's like trying to trick you into
thinking he was and he just wasn't so
that works me a little bit I've mixed
feelings about the supporting cast on
this river I mentioned is great Ian
Glenn fantastic I especially loved the
last line he says the doctor I think sir
you knew me at my best
he's wonderful but we have an entire
squad of completely useless faceless I
would say nameless but they do all get
named but who cares
you know just soldiers and that bothers
me because especially in a two-parter I
would like to feel like these are
fleshed out characters I would like to
feel the dynamic that they have with
other characters that isn't just
following orders I want it to feel more
like the team on the impossible planet
and the Satan pit or the heck the team
in waters of Mars which wasn't a
two-parter but was it a special so it
was longer or hey you know Ross from
Sontaran stratagem poisoned sky I want
that kind of feeling if you're gonna
give me a two-parter with characters
that continue over the course of it well
we just got fodder the only one who gets
any personality at all is Bob and they
also bungle some of the ways these
things are executed because if you
haven't rewatched this in a while
prior to Bob getting killed and his boy
becoming angel Bob which is actually
quite cool I do enjoy that so again like
I keep coming I'm doing mostly
complaining this but there are a lot of
things a lot of moments a lot of lines a
lot of ideas a lot of specific scenes
that are great but you know I'd like I
said I feel like this thing gets
overpraised and I need to nitpick a bit
here but prior to Bob there are two
other soldiers there's Angelo and
Christian and they go off and then one
of them goes off on his own to check
something
here's over the radio Angelo come and
look at this then the other one goes off
so like we know they're dead and then
the same thing happens to Bob the thing
is we have gotten to know Bob and we
care a bit about him
but we now already know that this entire
thing he's gonna end up with him dying
there was no need to show Angelo and
Christian going off and implying that
they got gotten by the Angels what
should happen was Bob was just sent off
you know go to the entrance with Angelo
and Christian he goes they're not there
and then the scene plays out as it
always does he hears over the radio he
goes to check out where they say tomb to
meet them and then he gets killed the
earlier thing showing the two of them
adds nothing similarly when the soldiers
are checking out the crack in time and
they start disappearing
it's Crispin and it's Pablo and there's
there's another one whose name I can't
remember now but like they go through
they go through three segments of them
going and then disappearing and not
being remembered it's at least one too
many you don't need to do it this many
times I do wonder sometimes if Steven
Moffat if he thinks his audience aren't
as clever as he is because a lot of the
clever ideas and it's happened to a
certain degree in his or any stuff but
it's like a big offender in this one
that the clever ideas get signposted or
reiterated one more time than is
necessary to make the point it's like he
thinks we're thick not completely but
like enough that we need to be shown
demonstrate to them one more time let's
be sure they're caught up and that's
what it feels like it feels
condescending and and and actually as a
result it makes Amy
seem really dumb because she has nothing
to do all she can do is like well tell
me what's going on tell me tell me and
like they tell her but she keeps going
telling me tell me cuz we have to
stretch out the scene because we have to
go through this entire cycle with three
different sets of characters why
absolutely no need for that
similarly the thing about the aplans
having the two heads that gets
signposted i'd say at least one more
time than it needed to I'm not gonna
knock on that one too much because I I
at least to my memory my first time
watching it I didn't catch it until I
was expected to so fine but I think I
still would have caught it if you'd sign
posted it one less time than is actually
in there I think it still would have
worked and then it would have lessened
the risk of me having figured out before
the other characters there's a lot of
great ideas here and overall the
structure of it I like I like the threat
of it I actually again I think the
angels are really well used here
regardless of what you think happen with
them later I think their use here is
solid the new idea is brought into play
with them are cool new ideas but there's
a lot of small moments that don't work
there's a lot of ideas that it could
have been presented better or could have
been presented more smoothly or subtly
or just you know with a little bit more
respect for the intelligence of the
audience at times it is still good I
don't want you to listen or watch me
complain about this and think it means
it's not good it is but it's it's not
that this episode specifically cuz I
don't actually feel this about Steven
Moffat at his best but definitely in
this instance he's not as clever as he
thinks he's being not on this one and
and I'm getting that sort of resentment
that I get when I watch something or I
read something by someone who see at
least it comes across like they think
they are distinctly cleverer than their
audience and it comes across at times as
condescending and self-congratulatory
and I get that vibe off this two-parter
not massively but it is there a little
bit it does soften my enjoyment of what
is otherwise a pretty dang good story
and
again it's still good I don't skip this
one
I have rewatched it prior to doing it
for this so I do enjoy it and so many
fantastic lines you know the the doctor
oh you lot you breed like rabbits I'll
never be done saving you there's so many
great little lines like that from him
from father Octavian from River from ami
great moments the doctor comforting ami
in the in the forest especially if you
know what happens later on with the big
bang like great stuff but just for how
tightly some of this is how loose other
parts of it is and that it's all it's
going from that tight loose tight loose
tight loose in the same story yeah that
bugs me time of the angels and flesh and
stone' did you have Yuri watched it
lately what you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
other stuff down there as well there's
the stuff that you know because there
you can subscribe you can like there's
also a patreon you can support me there
the amount helps even a dollar a month
and given that I'm doing four videos a
week that works out to be pretty cheap
on a per video of basis if you want to
help me out there help grow the channel
help me cover my bills in addition to
that there's other stuff besides links
to my social there's a p.o box if you
feel like sending me stuff some folks do
I appreciate it but in any case so many
things you can take a look at click on
them or don't you don't have to because
at the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]